we were like how old are you they're
like 14 we're like no dude what the heck
they're like you don't think I'm pretty
the legal age for consensual sex in in
in Czech Republic is 14 oh went
oh well I guess I do
partake well I have never been want to
sh away from some
[Laughter]
[Music]
culture welcome back to careful boys
we're today talking about what was our
most memorable culture shock moment in
another country
o culture shock moment culture shock CCH
Republic oh I know what happened oh
thanks for just
joing mine
was so I've been going to Taiwan since I
was a kid U maybe even like when I was
like maybe three or four and almost
every year at least once and so I've
always been living I kind of like
understood like okay there's American
way of life and then there's uh the
Asian way of life and then when I was
19 I went with my friends to Mexico for
the first time and we drove past the
border and you know you there's so many
Mexicans here you just feel like oh cool
Mexico is probably like an extension of
America or whatever and people go to
like Tijuana Rosarito it's it's probably
just like I don't know like a big San
Diego or something like that and I
remember driving through in the middle
of the night and uh must have been like
maybe 11:00 p.m. 12 it's like pitch
black and it's you're on a kind of like
a dirt road I remember getting pulled
over by a police truck and there's like
four cops in the back and they have AKs
they come out and then they're like you
guys are speeding and we're like oh
sorry sir and all four of us were
Marines and we're like oh no we're I'm
sorry we we wouldn't have been because
we respect that we're in a different
country we're sort of following all the
speed limits or whatever they search all
of our [__] and they're like no you guys
are speeding we're going to have to take
you back to the police station we like
what the [__] and then they're like well
how much money you guys have mhm and
then so we're like what what do you mean
he goes cuz if there's enough we could
probably just like you know just turn a
blind eye so we're like [__]
scouching up cash or whatever and then
we gave it to him go was like all right
uh slow down and then I remember going
like did we just [__] get jacked by
cops what the [__] is this and I
remember so we still went down to
Rosarito had a good time whatever and
when we came back when we passed the
like welcome to United States like
Customs [__] thing I remember going
yeah oh my
God I was
like cuz I'm like if that could happen
what else could [__] oh if you can
get Jack from cops and then in Rosarito
um I saw a cop on a [__] horse at
like 4:00 a.m. painted like a zebra
there's a there's a [__] chick yeah
there's a [__] uh a a drunk dude
drunk girl [__] Ola what you doing
and they're [__] like flirting or
whatever the [__] cop Coes up with
the horse knocks the guy over and just
starts flirting with the chick that's
sick I'm just like this place is [__]
crazy I need to get the [__] out of here
and when I came back it felt like I want
to just like I [__] love
California K some yeah yeah yeah
Gavin I'm like as much [__] as we have
here I'll never recall you again it's
different than when you go to another
country and there's no order it's like
what the f yeah yeah it's [__] I
couldn't believe it dude I went to to
[__] Hawaii right get off the plane
they put this fuzzy necklace on you and
I was like what the heck fuzzy
necklace that was the craziest damn
thing we ain't need America no more boys
I was like whoa what's happening go
check what was your Czech culture shop
uh the uh it was when me and Mike song
went to a dance camp in the Czech
Republic and it was just in some
secluded ass place you know far away
from like the regular City and then uh
they had an Afterparty at this Camp
right which was basically just the
little bar at this like c community
center or whatever so we went there and
people started eating drunk and then in
the middle of it they [__] turn off
the lights while the music is blasting
and it's just dark I'm talking small
room it's just black next thing you know
when we saw somebody open the door for a
second a flashlight came in half the
people were just making out things were
going crazy and then next thing you know
these these young kids students at the
camps are grabbing me and Mike right to
you know do some stuff and we're like no
like no we can't do that they're like
why they looked at us like we were
[__] being disrespectful like you
don't want to kiss me fool yeah it was
literally like that we're like no but
they're like 12 and [__] or what we like
how old are you they're like 14 we're
like no dude what the heck and but
here's the crazy European girls look
super developed compared to like you
know us Asian counterparts if you will
so it's really hard to tell how old they
are so you still got asking like 14 and
they're like or no they said they were
15 or 16 whatever right like7 18 19
whatever yeah 20131 no no we we we're
like too old they're like why and then
they looked at us and we were so
confused they're like they're like you
don't think I'm pretty the legal age for
consensual sex in in in Czech Republic
is 14 oh went
oh well how about that [__] stepen
Hawkins come through what's up D and
then did you throw the imaginal
imaginary lasso on excuse me you well I
guess I do
partake well I never been want to sh
away from some
culture prob be it for me to be a snob
in another country not me sir not no no
no not well how damn God damn then he
just starts talking when in Rome like
well those Americans well we didn't know
nothing about that it's like a Looney
Tunes moment he's a southern B that's
crazy no but it was just such a trip
because it's like if that's your rules
you're like whoa so I didn't want to be
disect but like because it's not our
rules it don't work it just doesn't work
so me you can make it work
man you can make it work Anthony
baby some people got different
thresholds I mean how are we talking
about
yeah that's when you start you know you
start really taking a good look in the
mirror you know jeez I like the 3 two
one Darkness like they all knew what to
do crazy they're like you pick your guy
wow I mean that's crazy if you went to
another state where the age is 16 that
would still be weird yeah could happen
domestically a 14 I mean imagine going
to Tennessee and then the lights turn
off and everyone's [__] the donkeys
and [__] that's and they're like what's
wrong our aren't good enough my donk is
12 what the [__] don't want to be one sh
around from culture a 3 two
one that's [__] crazy though holy
[__] an's lived many lives yeah what did
you guys do go back to the hotel room
and go like what the how did you and
Mike talk about it afterwards yeah we
were so mind blown that we were like
silent as we're walking back to our room
because again it wasn't like dude what
you had that was weird it was like a
damn we don't know this world you know
what I mean you just felt so displaced
cuz it's already one thing for us to be
like the Asian dudes in like Europe it's
like very clear like these [__] Ching
chongs are walking around our area you
know what I mean what if afterwards
they're like they were gay yeah probably
you know they're like there's nothing
wrong with you girl those girls are
probably cing afterwards like they
didn't think we were hot there's
something for gay guys like that too
yeah and also it really just depends on
your threshold like at the same time
like some other teachers at the camp you
know oh probably like the last teachers
were fine with it
oh it happens you never know happens
mine was in Thailand I was about 13 or
14 and it was the first time seeing
child soldiers and that was like the
biggest eye opener cuz we were in a Mong
Village two three hours away from Chang
Ma and uh that area too A lot of the
Mong tribes the only way they made money
was through heroin like growing poppies
and then like the drug lord would come
collect them and when I say drug lord
we're just talking about normal people
They didn't have an economy so they
would come through get the hero uh poppy
[__] and then they would just leave
bring like fruits and bananas like it's
a normal transaction right so it's not
like a general with a eye patch or
something no it's not gangster at all so
it's just an unarmed Village that does
all that right and I guess they heard
across the border there's Burma they
have like militia groups and terrorist
groups there and they heard that
missionaries were in the village so they
came through it was like you know in
Mexico you see like the police like in
the back of a pickup truck with guns so
we saw like a couple of those roll in
the village and they're like hide you
guys got to hide and then so we went in
and we're just looking outside from like
the house oh [__] and there were all
these kids that were like our age Junior
High age with like some adults and they
were just holding like guns like AKs all
that and some of them it was like as
tall as they were they were just holding
it and we're just looking like what the
[__] this is crazy and then the Village
leader came out they broke her out a
deal they paid him off and then some of
the kids just stuck around like people
were trying to go in the bathroom and
they're just like trying to do like Peep
and Tom [__] they were like normal kids
laughing looking at us waving at us but
they just had [__] guns what did you
guys think at that time were you guys
thinking like holy [__] this could have
been my life I I was shocked I was like
what the [__] this is crazy and like
later on in life I understood what a
Child Soldier was but I was like why the
[__] do all these kids my age have guns
and then they got back in the truck and
they told us later like yeah that was
just um like a you know like those
groups and then they had a broker a deal
and God saved us and this and that I was
like d Jesus dude yeah that was the
craziest but I was at the me and Nikki
went to the Bahamas right and we were
staying at the Atlantis over there and
the guy who like when we were getting
checked in he was like you absolutely
have to try there's one dish like make
sure you get it while you're here and so
I ordered it and it's like it's like
shrimp right but then they cover it with
like deep fried coconut flakes oh yeah
and I was like oh dude I am in another
country so [__] you and you in these
bumpers between
stories talking about my cult talking
about cult experiences he went from
chicken nuggets culture shock I'm
talking about culture sh he went from
chicken nuggets to coconut shrimp dude
to be fair I mean look at him yeah come
on it's probably a you know you know the
saddest [__] though i' be seeing people
in Vegas and that's exactly I know
exactly the they save [__] so many
years they're like from Kansas and then
they go to Vegas and then they go to PF
chains and they're like Chinese food
that's exotic they want us to eat with
two sticks over here can I get a spoon
please and they're like we're staying at
the the [__] pyramid one oh my god
well when you see that kind of cult holy
[__] you see how they lived you see how
they
liveed I was recently Kyoto and like
only the white people were dressed up in
kimonos and stuff yeah dude that's dope
that's dope I was like yo they're in
there's probably hella Chinese but you
just can't tell cuz they look the same
that's racist I don't like I didn't like
that that's one of my dreams is going to
China and getting orange chicken like
real orange chicken you probably can't
even find it just called chicken there
oh is that what it is okay I was in
Beijing and I was like where's the
beiging beef what the [__] yeah yeah
yeah I'm going to do that beef I'm do
both of those things oh uh one shock was
when I went to Paris I didn't realize
how [__] filthy it was when I was on
the way there it was worse than Skid Row
there's nothing but like bums and Tents
and like hella [__] like whole parks
of just refugees Paris is dirty that's
an actual syndrome though isn't it Paris
syndrome oh really what's Paris syndrome
it's like tourists that had dreams of
coming to Paris and they saved up their
money and then they get there and it's
almost like a System Shock to them that
they have to go to the hospital yeah
because it's so not like what they
imagine because it's so not and they
spent 9 GS I go to the hospital cuz I
spent N9 GS and it was a real thing a
lot of Chinese tourists were getting
hospitalized for that yeah what the [__]
they should go to China see how shitty
that place is Ja it's Japanese tourist
it was Japanese tours cuz you know how
clean Japan is and if it's your first
trip you just don't understand how dirty
some place can be so they're like going
around Paris and they're crying cuz it's
[__] like hysterically crying God so
interesting that reminds me of a I just
saw something on Twitter you probably
saw us too I think our algorithm's like
dead on the same um this chick was in
Paris and she's like just talking to
herself on camera but she puts it up
right and she's talking about how she
came to Paris and she thought it was
going to be all great and like it's very
lonely there and everyone's really mean
to her and like it's really sucks here
and I wouldn't recommend coming here
like same [__] there's that one black
kid he was like going around the streets
hey y'all Paris is [__] or like he was
talking all that [__] it was so [__]
Creator did that too oh Tyler was the
best he dunked over was talking [__] on
talking on it that's funny I love Paris
but I also know when I go there it's
going to [__] smell and look like
[__] half the time but like the things
that you enjoy about or things that you
do romanticize about still cool still
there but also like if you've met
someone from Paris that lives here now
they'll say the same [__] because then
you're you're kind of they complain
about per The Way We complain about Cali
yeah Nick where you been I'm trying to
think of the time where I've been most
culture shocked but it's
like probably Singapore when I was a kid
and I saw him eat some diran and I was
like you guys eat this [__] I really
what a Steve dude you guys eat this [__]
smells like [__] gasoline yeah let
them know what it smells like probably
it was when I was in Al Salvador El
Salvador or Bali cuz like it's different
when you see like third world poverty
and [__] you know like when you're in it
and just driving around and you're like
oh yeah pave roads is a luxury yeah yeah
yeah yeah being able to drive your car
through the dirt and to be able to make
it through is like a luxury like this
[__] really needs to happen and you see
it like in El Salvador when I was there
for a short period of time you just see
everyone has a hustle everyone's selling
bread People are cleaning clothes for
their neighbors so they could get $11 by
the end of like two weeks you know like
everyone's just hustling everyone's just
driving around and then the way they
looked at me when I was at the uh cuz I
was in like a smaller town um and
there's obviously not that many Asian
people if there any nearby but as soon
as I was walking around with like our
family they would always be like they
they'd be like gra like look at the
Cheeto yo what the [__] like that's
definitely a trip no matter where you go
like but you kind of look indigenous you
could pass for no for sure but they saw
they knew but they were like that is a
Chino it just smelled they knew
something was up and they just kept
being like hey yo come to my stand like
come check out what I'm selling like do
they look at you as a cash or like more
like a um or more like a
chinoo kind of but because I was with
people who are local to that area it was
like kind of fine and it was like it was
more like more jokey and less uh like I
didn't I didn't actually feel scared if
I was by myself I might have been like
yo what the [__] is this but because you
know you're with locals is fine but
probably that man like cuz I've been to
well I actually haven't been to that
many places I don't think about it
besides like Central America and
freaking Asia that's about it you've
been to San Marino I want to go to
Central America dude your trip looks so
fun it's all the street food all that
[__] you guys were that [__] was great
bro yeah Bali was crazy too but it's I
think it's very similar that way too
where you see how crazy the roads are
and you see how packed everything is
everyone's on these little mopeds and
you're like oh well yeah this is nothing
like this nothing like La there nothing
like California this is whack but I went
on a cruise to Mexico many years ago
with Nikki and hang
on hang on hang on all right so we get
to Mexico right and as soon as we're in
Mexico I went up to cuz they had this
like huge buffet in the Carnival Cruise
or whatever and I went up to the guy and
I was like hey can I get a pizza and
he's like yeah sure and I was like
technically isn't that now a Mexican
pizza and I
went
and and then the guy didn't even
laugh he's like
okay sure I did something stupid like
that when I booked the cruise for the JK
trip I thought it was going to be a
three Mexican city tour and then the
first one was at uh Santa Barbara Oh
yeah and when we stopped at Santa
Barbara I was like what the [__] this is
not Mexico I mean that's a culture shock
in a different way I thought the first
stop was going to be Santa Barbara
California I mean and then maybe when
you read the broch show you were like oh
Santa Sant yeah cuz it was like in Sant
something else like oh cool hell yeah I
know those that's what I thought was
going to go on yeah Santa Barbara and I
was like what the [__] dude I've been
here before I remember getting culture
shock the other way in Japan though
going like oh yeah like oh [__] we can
get our [__] together if we wanted to oh
like a positive shot yeah just like you
go to any public area everyone's [__]
on the right side that's true [__]
everyone gets in line no trash on the
floor like people like they don't want
to inconvenience each other you're like
dude like we could actually be organized
if we wanted to but we just we were all
just if we were all just one race I just
I just came back from Japan with Nina
for the first time she was just tripping
about all that stuff so that was a huge
cold shock for her like why is it so
different yeah and I was like dude this
here's the difference in America
everyone's a main character in Japan
everybody's just part of the movie you
know what I mean for the good of the
nation man yeah okay actual answer now
at last I was uh in Singapore teaching
like uh you know like screenwriting
stuff to like um students part of part
of this program it really cool they were
really awesome but I started to like you
know I was doing like I don't know
anti-government bits and they were like
really seriously like hey dude you can't
you can't do that here like you cannot
do that here and they were like dead ass
serious and I was like oh [__] like I am
truly in some serious [__] like damn I
thought I had a freedom of speech cuz
back in our government we could do
anti-government [__] yeah we could duck
all over them as much as we want kind of
and then what happened what is it what
happened after that well then I had some
Singapore and chicken
nuggets and uh they were very good and I
had them with mustard there's the
kicker how about
that